more than three decades folks in
California have been enjoying Mulberry
Street Pizza and now Las Vegas and
visitors from all over the world are
getting a slice or two at Resorts World
Darren trepicio is the GM of Mulberry
Street Pizzeria thanks for being here
today thank you for having me this is
great you guys have been open for more
than a year now right yeah so we just
recently celebrated a year in business
at Resorts World Las Vegas that's the
property that we are in and it's just
been absolutely extraordinary being part
of it I think the the property is
fantastic beautiful it's trying to be
the best on the strip and at Mulberry
we're no exception we want to be the
best too and we bring in all these
signature and specialty pizzas too we
want to give you see if you give it a
try I do want to talk about these pizzas
and I do want to try them for sure this
what I love about this it's a family
business started more than 30 years ago
in Southern California if I'm not
correct in Beverly Hills and two in the
valley and your uncle started that's
right Richie Palmer and he started after
doing 20 years of pizza in New York so
he's very familiar with New York and all
that he grew up there grew up in the
Bronx and so bringing it out to Beverly
Hills it's now there for 30 years and
it's just been an absolute staple of Los
Angeles and in Beverly Hills an
institution in Beverly Hills and this is
the first Las Vegas or any location
outside of California right first
location in New York then I did okay
yeah hence the uh yeah oh that's great
all right so tell us about the pizzas we
got here yeah absolutely so first we're
looking at here is a buffalo chicken
pizza got a little bit of a bite to it
with a buffalo sauce but it's balanced
out with the ranch tomatoes and basil
this one's got a great flavor and it's
our top seller this is the big one right
here this is one that does really I'm
gonna try it while you talk about that
okay great yeah so here's our chicken
ranch pizza is a whole it's a property
favor I should say it's got Ranch
underneath the cheese breaded chicken
turkey pepperoni and basil and a lot of
people like that for turkey pepperoni oh
really and it's that's a great taste too
what do you think of that I love that
fantastic all right this again is the
buffalo chicken buffalo chicken okay
yeah and that's our top seller out of
the cheese and pepperoni people always
go to Buffalo chicken
and then here's our rigatoni Pizza this
is like a margarita pizza but we put the
ricotta cheese on the bottom and the
rigatoni pasta on top and of course a
pizza sauce drizzle in the basil and
that's my personal favorite out of three
to tell you uh that's really good now
did your uncle come up with all these
different ingredients and and
combinations
and people have loved them obviously do
you have some of the more traditional
Fair like if somebody wants to come in
for a pepperoni that's exactly right and
and that will never go lost there's
always cheese and pepperoni and in fact
the cheese you know in some comes in the
store I always say you know really if
you want to know that our pizza is
really good you got your cheese but you
know we've done these Specialties and
signature pies to show uh to show our
customers that we can do way more pizza
than just your traditional and that we
want to do more and show that it's a
meal within a slice you were telling me
this is one of your favorites right it's
really good yeah that's the pasta pizza
right yeah Erica Tony rigatoni okay
that's fantastic so is your the
restaurant for people who haven't been
there the kind where you can come in and
sit down or is it walk away or how does
it work it's like fast casual so you
want to come in for a slice and bleed
boom you're there or you want to sit
down and sit down with the family and
that's very popular as well and endure
you know during the week we get more
customers and clientele for the property
that stay at the property just for the
pizza which has been so cool yeah it's
fantastic it's great and then you we're
right next to the hottest nightclub in
the city Zoop nightclub and so that's
our weekend at late at night we're open
late at night we'll close at like five
in the morning oh my gosh yeah and they
come out and what's better than a slice
of pizza at night especially yes for
those who have been partying quite a bit
I'm sure it hits the spot right and if
you stay if you have a table in the club
we'll bring the pie to you too and we do
that with the VIP host and they're all
they're all terrific that's fantastic
and you guys have done so well obviously
in California but now here in Las Vegas
congratulations for all the success
you're a joy thank you well deserved I
might add all right so if you want to
try that rigatoni Pizza is fantastic
you're right the buffalo chicken is good
it had over two Mulberry Street Pizzeria
at Resort